the feminism lies to women
it lies no radical feminism does
i think all feminism i don't think we
need feminism in 2022. i think it's
outdated and there's nothing that i
can't do today that a man can do there's
no nothing legally in my way
like there's no law we're fighting for i
i don't see the name right that's
different for every woman so like say
for example me and you uh-huh you can
walk into an office and demand a job
they'll give it to you if i ask for it
they'll be like what is this black
monkey doing here like get out
and then say for example you and a man
if you both walked in okay say for
example you and a white man okay talk to
him okay he's not like oh sorry he's
more likely to get the job than you
there's still that type of thing
that's not true that's not true the wage
gap doesn't exist
it doesn't when you take into account
the diff no it doesn't like any any
psychologist that's worth assault will
tell you that it does not exist the
people that the people that the people
that
are that that talk about that are
reiterating it for their political gain
they're saying that to confuse you and
to control you i mean i've seen it no no
no no so so the reason when you take
into account
personality differences
and and roles that women pick so women
tend to pick jobs that are with people
men tend to pick jobs with things so
therefore men make more money because
those jobs pay more for example men pick
engineering more than women that's a
very high paying career men pick
plumbing
bricklaying
garbage garbage collection that stuff is
that pays more than being like a
psychologist
i'm not depends because what's it
um
studies that i've seen so i did a study
on like
basketball okay it's quite evident the
men get paid a lot more than me because
they bring in because because they bring
in more money i know they're bringing
more money but so so why would you pay
someone if they're not making money like
that's like me that's like if you have
more money they could probably perform
to the level where they'd get the same
amount of money no they don't they don't
no no they don't the wnba is at a 10
million loss every year they lose money
they don't make money so so that's like
me having 10 salesmen and the men
bring me in let's say 50k each a year
then women lose me 20k are they given
the same facilities because you could be
giving these men fancy offices and then
the women's workforce
do you think that lebron james dunking
is more entertaining
as equally as entertaining as like the
one or two women that conduct
a woman duncan is quite impressive
all the time so it's just like it's
impressive it's impressive but is it as
entertaining do you i think so well
that's me either but someone's the
exception or the rule do more people
want to watch the nba or the wnba it
depends on which one's publicized more
which is the mba but it's not as
publicized
no it's because men are men are better
at basketball well i didn't want to say
that's the bottom line i play i play
basketball
and even even at let's take uel i'm
sorry i'd rather watch the men's over us
true
that way though
in what we in the sense that
as you mentioned before in terms of the
pay gap or the one doesn't exist
obviously men will take more laborious
jobs right so the more the engineering
things actually takes on the physicality
of a man yeah
hence why us women get paid less we do
the admin jobs the personal jobs yeah
when you're comparing it versus football
to football for example
my cousin she's a female she plays
football
she actually posts something yesterday
the pay gap in football is mad it's
crazy and i was and i see what you're
saying about what would you rather watch
but why is it why do you want to watch
men play football versus women's yeah
shape who who would win in an arm
wrestling match oh absolutely exactly
that's different
things but you know in the sense of an
exactly it's the same game basketball
football it's the same game no but these
things do come into play strength yeah
yeah
yeah
that comes into it does come into play
we're just better at it the closest i've
seen to the gap being pushed to a degree
is tennis with the williams sisters but
they're still yeah
where they play to such a level but
they're still these are yeah the 200th
ranked man beat serena williams thank
you i was about to say that
yeah like men are just better at sports
they're bigger they're stronger they're
faster so they deserve to get paid more
yeah they yeah because if you're better
at a job you get paid more average thank
you so why don't they'll
just the same way i think there's like
men will never bridge the gap in
modeling but you don't hear anything
about that
you don't hear men complaining oh we
don't make as much on only fans like
we don't know even though even though
it's the same even though nobody felt
like that industry was built by men
anyway so most that's the men's fault
anyway
what so only friends like porn industry
that's basically built by men so it's
the men's fault that they don't get
enough views i know so what's the
difference
men watch sports
yeah yeah so i'm saying like like at the
end of the day you get paid for eyeballs
in both professions you get paid for who
watches more yeah and so one it's women
taking off their clothes and men taking
off clothes and in the other it's
playing a sport
yes so but i'm saying like why don't
nobody
rallies marches the streets
for i agree with you
for the men not getting paid enough to
model yes i think i mean they're not
really triggered by it
no because men don't complain women do
women women women will complain about
everything i'm complaining if i wasn't
earning enough money
that the money you'd complain if you
don't earn the money if you're earning
the money you deserve to earn
basically i feel like they deserve it i
think they deserve less actually if
you're operating at a loss i think they
probably don't like if we're going to go
off with deserve like
if if i had a sales person and they were
losing me money like
ish right there he has a job because i
make more money on the streams than he
like than he costs
right
but if we if these streams were really
bad and every time i lost viewers every
time he came on like
what he wouldn't be here and it's the
same thing with like the wnba in the nba
they have they have people yes if it was
performance related play related pay a
lot of these women wouldn't there would
might be no basketball league for women
um
but i think it's probably because it's
more recent thing
what's that you think as time goes by
women will get better
no because i feel like the men have had
a head start
if that makes sense so basketball
[Laughter]
a head start
no but in terms of like leagues these
are still new leagues
so
that's what i'm trying to say because
the demand for the men's league was
there like i'm telling you people want
to make money
people like
people will put anything on a screen to
make money if women's sports made money
it would be pushed they just did the
boxing the other day in new york they
did um
the big all women's fight first time
every madison square garden
um katie taylor versus amanda serrano
that got a big push that was a landmark
moment but again how much of that was
partly like
the novelty of it at the same time
because
you know men do that every week
and do you think women should box do you
like women boxing
if they like it then they like it i
personally don't like boxing as a whole
but they're saying if i don't mind they
might as well both box if two women were
boxing
and one and one of them battered bruce
get enough would you think you'd be more
inclined to say stop the fight than you
would if it was two men
you're not in your hands i want to see
women fighting wood
you've gone into fight and now you want
to stop the fight just continue
if she dies she does
nice i'm saying instinctively you you
might want to like like emily said she
would be more inclined to say i would i
would yeah well and i would as well so
i'm saying it nothing that's just me
that i'm like